one of my objections was Muhammad used  violence and then yeah I read of course  Moses used violence as well and  especially the guy who followed Moses  when Moses died Joshua is a prophet as  well in the Old Testament and he was he  used a lot of violence and when I  compared the teachings when it came to  war between the Bible and the Quran I  found out that that what the Quran for  example says you can have killed women  children now all the things you you  probably know but in the Bible there are  passages that say the opposite they say  you have to kill women kill it kill them  all and of course and let's be happy  that that's not what the the most  Christian churches teach but there are  passages in the Old Testament that that  say that you have to wipe out everything  even the grass so everything has to  there be erased